hey everybody John Luke here bringing  you some lawbreakers PC beta gameplay of  the juggernaut class in fact this is the  best match I've ever had in lawbreakers  and probably ever will so enjoy the open  beta runs till July 3rd so get in it  while you can and give us a like and sub  if you want to see even more lawbreakers  coverage from us thanks for watching  ugly acquired  the uplink connected  your uplink is that 25%  [Music]  killstreak  annihilation  [Music]  [Music]  your team scores  uplink initializing  awfully acquired  your uplink is that 25%  your uplink is at 50%  your uplink is almost complete  [Music]  chill Street  [Music]  I restored  you win  [Music]